Mists from flammable fuels can easily  catch fire here you can see jet fuel  exploding at 1,000 frames per second not  something you want to have happen when  transporting it around long polymer  molecules have been considered as a way  to reduce the risk of fire by  controlling these mists but these  additives can bind up machinery or they  can be damaged as the fuel is pumped now  a new mega super molecule has been  created that does not have these  problems the new molecule is made from  two shorter molecules that strongly  stick together they can break a part of  the pump but come together again  afterwards importantly the pieces  associate end to end not in circles or  flower shapes retaining length and  letting them do their job the same  experiment this time with the polymer  added results in no fire